Welcome back everyone it's Charlie this will be my
new house of the dragon season 2 video about all
the new characters or the biggest new characters
that are coming to season 2 a couple of them they
teased during season 1 or we saw them briefly and
they'll be much bigger characters during season
2 and some are just completely new people that
we've never heard about before if you're brand
new to the channel I'll be doing videos all the
way during the off season be sure to subscribe
to get them all but one of the biggest characters
is going to be Daeron Targaryen alicent's fourth
child with viserys he's actually in the intro
during the last couple of episodes but we
didn't actually see him because he's been a page
down in Old Town this entire time and they just
haven't had time to go down to Old Town and spend
a couple episodes down there there wasn't really a
reason to include him in season one which is why
George RR Martin said no no he's alive he's just
down there we'll see him during season two the
next big one is maelor targaryen the third child
of aegon II and Helaena Targaryen he's alive
because we saw him in the intro scene as well
same situation is Daeron Targaryen he was just
a very young child he doesn't have a dragon just
because he's not old enough yet but they do have
a dragon egg earmarked for him and even though
it's a bit of a funny Easter egg they're all the
Muppet based Game of Thrones characters showing
up in House of the Dragon season 2. there's a
Grover Tully and Elmo Tully a Kermit Tully and
an Oscar Tully I'm sure there'll be all kinds of
memes during season two George R Martin just a
really big Jim Henson Sesame Street and Muppets
fan remember they control riverrun right now so
they need to bargain with them to get support in
the dance of the dragons the next biggest one is
Cregan Stark who I already did a big video about
so I'll link it at the end of this and down in the
description below he is basically the current Lord
of Winterfell when season two picks up I explained
at length the circumstances of how he became the
Lord of Winterfell his father was rickon stark the
one who bent the knee to rhaenyra back in episode
one but ricken died during that giant time Jump
between episode 5 and episode 6 and there was this
big Civil War within the Stark family so they had
their own battle for the succession Kragen wound
up winning and taking Winterfell like he should
then there's Sara snow his bastard half-sister
I also talked a little bit about her during my
video for Cregan Stark her story with jacaris is a
little bit like rhaegar Targaryen story with with
lyanna stark and Jon Snow so just more references
back to A Song of Ice and Fire because of what
jaceris winds up doing with Sara snow he and Craig
and Stark who he's supposed to get along with form
what they call The Pact of Ice and Fire which is
different from A Song of Ice and Fire but just
a big reference to that then there's Jeyne Arryn
Lady of the Vale. She's been ruling over the vale
by herself since her husband died a long time
ago but she's been in charge of the veil since
the reign of joharis the first like for a long
time when season two picks up one of the reasons
why she's a big to rhaenyra is because she went
through the exact same thing that rhaenyra went
through because she was a woman a lot of the other
Lords in the vale didn't want her to claim the
veil and start ruling over it by herself basically
it's the same situation with rhaenyra like we know
we don't want a Woman by herself on the Iron
Throne so all the Lords of the realm the greens
are causing all these problems for her which is
what led to the dance of the dragons in the books
Jane is also a lesbian which is why she's also
sympathetic to what rhaenyra went through with
her marriage to laenor velaryon so there's just a
lot of reasons why she's been very sympathetic to
rhaenyra's plight all these years there's game in
pale here he's actually the bastard child of aegon
II that we saw in flea bottom during season one
I wouldn't say he's a massive character but he's
still relatively important because his whole idea
of who has claims to the throne their ser Perkin
the Flea and trystane truefyre. Perkin to flee is
just a hedge Knight during the events of Dance of
the Dragons Who winds up using trystane truefyre
the bastard of viserys the first rhaenyra's father
like I said as the dance of the Dragons heats up
there are a lot of bastards with even a little bit
of Targaryen blood in their veins who try to make
claims to the Iron Throne there's Gwayne Hightower
alicent's brother the person that Daemon destroyed
during the tournament in episode 1 his father
Otto Hightower uses him in King's Landing as
a plant inside the gold cloaks to just keep
an eye on them and make sure that they don't rebel
against the throne we have all the dragon seeds in
the new dragons that they mentioned during season
one this is a chart that depicts the lineage of
all the dragons like where all the dragons came
from who laid the dragon eggs we saw vermithor
briefly at the end of season one but demon just
rattled off a whole bunch of names we'll see all
those dragons some of them are much bigger much
older but they all Roost on Dragonstone which
is why Daemon and ranera control them after vegar
Vermithor the one that we saw here is the biggest
oldest one he used to be ridden by King jaehaerys
the first before his death Silverwing was the
dragon that belonged to alysanne. Jaehaerys' wife,
same situation there she hasn't had a writer since
alysanne died a long time ago there's tyraxes baby
Joffrey's tiny dragon very small obviously Joffrey
not gonna do a whole lot of fighting because he's
so little then there's the three wild dragons
sheepstealer Cannibal and gray ghost and you have
the bigger Dragon Seed characters the characters
that have enough Targaryen blood are bastards
in the family and just capable of riding dragons
probably the biggest most famous one in the books
is Nettles she's actually a Velaryon bastard who
grew up in spicetown so it's implied that she's
one of the bastards of one of Corlys Velaryon's
family members if not him himself she winds up
writing sheepstealer one of the wild dragons
she's a really big character she's actually fairly
interesting and gets fairly involved with Daemon
so I'm expecting her to be a relatively big
character when they introduce her if you feel
like they did Laena Velaryon so dirty by skipping
so much of her story during her lifetime because
of all the time jumps they kind of make up
with that with nettle's character there's
Hugh Hammer and ulf white who are both Targaryen
bastards that grew up on Dragonstone that are just
regular members in their army when the dance of
the Dragons picks up but because they need all
the dragon seeds they're like anybody that has any
kind of Targaryen blood in your veins any Valyrian
Blood come talk to us we need Dragon Riders so
whereas before they would have just been relegated
to a life as relatively low ranking members in
the military they suddenly get giant promotions
because they become Dragon Riders. Hue Hammer
winds up being the one to ride vermithor an ulf
white winds up being the one to write Silverwing
there's Addam Velaryon who's supposed to be the
bastard son of corlys velaryon but what they might
do is they might change things and just make this
a version of Lenor Velaryon using a different
name pretending to be corliss's bastard and just
being a back door for coolest being able to pass
driftmark in all of his Holdings to laner which he
wanted to do a ridge originally because Addam
Velaryon in the books is the person who winds
up writing seasmoke in what bigger twist would
there be than laner just coming back pretending
to be a bastard having his head shaved so that
nobody completely recognizes who he is and just
takes back up on his old dragon like oh hey sorry
for the break sorry I was gone for a little while
but I'm back now there's the blood and cheese
characters who get referenced a lot just because
what they do winds up being really spoilery so
try not to talk about it too much but they're
basically ruffians living in fleabottom that
wind up being used by messeria for all kinds
of ill purposes and retaliations on the part of
Daemon Targaryen remember what happened at the end
of episode 10 the finale aemond wound up killing
luceris even if it was by accident he still killed
him so Daemon and rhaenyra want retaliation for
that that winds up being through the blood and
cheese characters what maseria winds up having
them do is so crazy in WTF we will spend a lot
of time talking about it when it actually happens
then there's Alys Rivers who winds up being the
concubine of aemond Targaryen so obviously he's
a huge fan of MILFs because of what's going on
with his sister Helaena Targaryen appreciate of
MILFs in Westeros there'll be all kinds of aiming
jokes during season two the big twist with Alys
Rivers though is her backstory she's actually
the bastard daughter of Lyonel Strong remember
father of Harwin Strong and Lara's strong Lord
weird footstuff and the reason why we make all
the aemond targaryen MILF jokes is because she's
about 40 years old when the events of the dance
of the Dragons begins so she's meant to be really
close to the same age as Harwin strong and larys
strong the obvious other reason why it's kind
of controversial is because of her relationship
with the blacks and rhaenyra's side like if she's
technically related to rhaenyra's firstly children
shouldn't she have some sort of allegiance to the
blacks but then you have like the full-blown
littlefinger level characters like Larys Strong
who are trying to play four-dimensional chess
obviously playing against his family in a very
big way there's the shepherd character who winds
up becoming kind of like a version of The High
Sparrow during the events of Game of Thrones much
later a leader of Faith militant characters big
Faith militant type of Uprising in King's Landing
is a reference to the growing danger of the faith
of the seven in King's Landing in general they
kind of teased that threat to during season 1
after the big time jumps because alicent and her
older age had become much more religious and she
was already part of the faith of the seven that's
why she walks around with the seven-pointed star
around her neck she put up symbols of the faith of
the seven all over the red keep in King's Landing
there were also a couple small Council meetings
where they referenced that the faith were asking
for more and more funds from the crown that winds
up becoming a much bigger thing during the events
of Season 2 Season 3 and so on one of the big
problems with the shepherd character is that
he really really hates rhaenyra because of all
the things that she's rumored to have done even
though all the rumors are true her first three
children were bastards her first husband was gay
obviously all things that the faith of the seven
completely hate does the rest of rhaenyra's black
council we already saw most of the rest of the
green council most of the characters that we
didn't see at the end of episode 10 that become
part of the black Council are just the Lords from
along the shoreline here in Blackwater Bay some of
them will be smaller characters like if you have a
giant room full of people standing around the map
table some of them will be like the character in
the background around just kind of standing there
but then it lines of dialogue there's the rest of
rhaenyra's Queensguard she had 2 during episode
10 and the idea is that you're supposed to have
seven at any given time there's a bunch more
minor lordlings of smaller houses in and around
the crown lands just because that's where a lot of
the conflict takes place then because the blacks
basically control all of the Eastern Seaboard
of Westeros the greens want more support from
the East that one's upcoming in Admiral Sharako
lohar of Lys who's an admiral of the triarchy
that winds up supporting them just to balance
out their side with veneers because remember
the Lannisters have this big Fleet but because
corlys velaryon controls the stepstones they're
of no use to the greens there's some big events
that Admiral Sharako becomes personally part of
I don't know if they're going to keep those during
season 2 or season 3 but he will wind up being a
much bigger character he also has a big connection
to an easter egg from back in episode 3. so if
you remember in episode 3 when they were talking
about the troubles that they were having with the
triarchy the first time when Lair is strong
first started infiltrating alicent's little
circle here you mind if I sit down and listen to
all the tea that you're pouring ring tell me all
of your secrets the women gossip about one of the
daughters from one of the noble houses house Swann
named Joanna Swann who winds up being ransomed
but her father didn't care about her and didn't
pay the ransom so she winds up being thrown into
a pleasure house in lys it's meant to be another
example of how rhaenyra and alicent basically have
to do whatever their fathers tell them to do like
you gonna marry this person you're gonna marry
that person and because of their station because
of the way the realm views them they can't really
say anything about it but the funny thing is is
that Joanna Swann character that got ransomed to
the pleasure house and list winds up becoming a
very powerful person in her own right referred
to as the Black Swann later becoming much more
of a mysaria type of character which is also
kind of what rhaenyra has been doing this whole
time also alicent tried to take power for herself
even though she's got involved in all that weird
foot stuff with larys strong the more powerful
Black Swann version of Joanna Swann also winds up
being another reference to what's happening with
rhaenyra and alicent just later in the timeline
like the realm didn't care about us before now
we're taking that power back for ourselves they're
probably going to be a couple other relatively
minor characters they'll introduce during the
season they might change a couple characters too
from the books as well but when we hear more about
that of course I'll do more videos but if you have
any other big questions about brand new characters
during season two just write them Below in the
comments I have a bunch more bonus videos planned
for the greens as well like aegon the second
Aemond Targaryen all the crazy stuff that's
going to be happening everyone click here to learn
more about what's going on with Cregan Stark and
Winterfell during season 2 and click here for my
episode 10 alternate ending and deleted scenes
video thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe and I'll see you guys in the next one!